[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] them
[Music]
528
[Music]
000 jobs dark
brandon
the job creator
oh
boy they're focusing on the wrong number
today aren't they they're like 87
000 irs agents that way our government
operates and that's a bad thing
528 000 jobs almost twice what the
expectation was for july
oh we're in a recession huh
i mean i've been saying it over and over
and over and over again
i keep saying it
the opposite of inflation is a recession
these [ __ ] boneheads who have been
harping on inflation and gas prices gas
prices
crude is now below 90 dollars a barrel
the first time since russia you invaded
ukraine the sovereign nation of ukraine
and putin is committing war crimes
a murderous dictator
a fascist murderous dictator
invades a sovereign country we put
sanctions we decide their oil is not
worth supporting and propping them up
a dictator like putin
and it takes a little bit to get the
supply under control
to drop the price
opec is going to release more supply
and
dark branding creates 528 000 jobs in
this u.s economy in the month of july
dropping unemployment
3.5
percent
so now now that unemployment is dropping
the talk of recession
hmm
that's not what happens during recession
during a recession when you're actively
entering a recession your unemployment
number doesn't go down
to three and a half percent
so not only are they lying about gas
prices
and they've been caught in their lie
because they were so [ __ ] dedicated
to the lie
now they're going to be caught in their
lie of recession
inflation inflation gas prices stuff's
so high it's so high recession look joe
biden's destroying the academy oh wait
you mean we created jobs
folks
the reason why they suck
is because it sucks to suck it really
does
and when you are horrible at [ __ ]
governing
when you have the reins of government
and you do a really shitty really shitty
job
and then and then folks who want to
govern they want to do policy
they want to do the thing i don't know
called democracy
get the reins of power and they do those
things
and all the dots connect
and it works just right it works just
right
their lies don't stand up
their lives don't stand up they lied oh
oh
you're being over dramatic
they won't take abortion rights away
from women especially in the exception
of their life
rape and incest there's no way that they
won't take away contraception they won't
want to marry children in tennessee no
way will they want to ban math in
florida
it's not possible for them to even
consider
getting rid of
same-sex marriage or interracial
marriage no way would they get rid of
marriage equality you're being over
dramatic
they've done all those things and
they've lied about every single one of
them
every single one of them they've lied
and they continue to lie about this
recession and the media buys it every
[ __ ] stupid time every [ __ ] stupid
time now they're they're actively the
fed is actively trying to
drive us into recession by costing
middle class people working class people
money by raising interest rates which is
way more expensive than inflation itself
so yeah the fed is doing something to
try to draw us into recession but we're
not having it
it's not changing demand
even raising the interest rates folks is
not changing demand
and the heated economy that we had
the very heated economy that we had was
on the tail end of a pandemic where we
were all locked locked up
in our homes we couldn't participate in
the economy like we wanted to and then
as soon as we wanted to we did and the
demand was there the other thing too
that i just i just want to add here the
reason why we were all able
we're all able to participate in the
economy is because of the democrats not
the republicans
in 20 in 2021 last year in the in the
spring
democrats passed the covet act
made sure the money got into the
american people's pockets not rich
people's pockets american people's
pockets and that's what he did our
economy jesus christ even the even the
housing market
is getting back to being sane
which is a good thing
property values are up
the market isn't crazy
people aren't fearing a 2008 all over
again
hopefully they'll start the fed will
come to their senses and start dropping
interest rates again
back to a decent level
oh so dark brandon's trending this
morning i'm going to show you a great
video that i found i love it i love this
dark brandon video that i
i found and then i i i really think that
the
internet embracing the name brandon and
turning it into this dark brandon thing
is exactly what is needed in this moment
but there's big news there's big news
there's not just great news on the
political front there's not just great
news on the economic front there's also
great news on the prosecution front
it appears that mark meadows may be
cooperating
and others may be cooperating in the
january 6 investigation with department
of justice
i guess trump lawyers is in contact with
dod trying to really figure out who are
the ones that are cooperating
and feeding information against him he
really needs to know
what crimes they're they're telling them
about
i can almost guarantee that mark meadows
has and will and
continue eastman will he's a frightened
little troll
and jeffrey clark the same way they're
[ __ ] they're completely [ __ ]
rudy giuliani is going to be is going to
turn against him they're all going to
turn against him
and this idea that the department of
justice and merrick garland aren't doing
their job it's a bunch of [ __ ]
[ __ ] same [ __ ] [ __ ] as gas
prices in recession
same [ __ ] [ __ ] same [ __ ] that
elon musk was gonna buy twitter
this is all a distraction to distract
you from the real threat the real threat
is them taking away your liberty fascism
is at the front door and we must engage
to stop it
boy i'm excited what a hell of a week
we've had here for democracy in this
country a hell of a week
a hell of a week and it keeps getting
better and better and better and that is
because people are participating in
their civic duty
to democracy
and as we do more and more of it it's
just going to get better uh larry
speaking the economy larry kudlow oh my
god
you remember this guy he was uh
he was in the trump white house he was
supposed to be some kind of great
economic advisor he's supposed to be so
[ __ ] smart
i mean he knows how to unders unscrew a
a bottle of alcohol apparently
but larry kudlow uh yesterday and i
think it was at this c-pack
can you believe that they're doing
another [ __ ] cpac anyways well maybe
we'll get to that
larry kudlow says yesterday oh the
economy's gonna crash and blah blah blah
and here's this report this morning
yeah okay
okay
of course larry kudlow's wrong why
wouldn't he be why wouldn't he be
lindsey graham is freaking out
also on the economic front freaking out
about the
the inflation reduction act you know
what i was thinking the other day
inflation reduction boy that's a great
name in this in this moment
for a bill that would pass the united
states senate why in the [ __ ]
why in the [ __ ] couldn't we do [ __ ] like
that
back last year we could call the bill
back better at which is a stupid [ __ ]
name by the way
the bill back better we could have
called that an inflation reduction act
how i was saying at the time that it's
inflation protection
the god damn child tax credit that was
be gonna be given to the american people
was inflation protection that's what it
was
hell that's what we were receiving for
over a year
was inflation protection i think they
should have extended it to all americans
the inflation protection in the form of
a tax credit
that's what they should have done and
they could have called it inflation
reduction act
and we'd already had bill back better do
you see how so important it is
to make sure we're behind all this stuff
to so to make sure the democrats know
hey we're for your messaging you just
lean into it
throw the punch stop holding your
punches
throw those [ __ ] throw hands
in this political climate that's what we
want you to do and we have to reward
them as they throw hands folks
we
as a people have to reward them
for doing the civic duty that they're
doing
because we've elected them to go do
policy for us
that is how we are the government
it's called a democratic constitutional
republic
for all those
trump symptoms out there that don't
understand language it's a democracy
i know there's a few of them that listen
to me i know they're here
i know they're here
they're here somewhere lurking around
the trump supporters they're especially
on facebook oh my god over on facebook
you know you know we we broadcast every
single weekday monday through friday
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific on
youtube twitter and twitch and we also
simulcast
from the midas touch facebook page
and boy boy does facebook have some
great trolls over there they were all up
in the comments yesterday it was
fantastic i love the trolls everyone
everyone hates trolls they don't like
trolls you know they say i love trolls
my moderators know
mj and robin know i i actually kind of
like the trolls as long as you're not
saying racist [ __ ] or you're not
attacking someone personally
in the comments
i like the trolls they pump the
algorithms they're here
they're here to help dark brandon they
just don't know it
oh this dark brandon shit's got me got
me rolling this morning i spent way too
much time on the dark brand and stuff
and not enough time on real things
did you are you doing the same thing
these memes these videos
you just you just can't help yourself
i can't help myself
oh what a great what a great week we've
had
now we've watched we've watched as the
the primaries went the way
that they that we thought they were
going to
we thought they were going to joe biden
looks like we're going to get the
inflation reduction act very soon in the
hands of the american people
which is going to reduce health care
costs and
get people
money back in their pockets the american
working class not not not the donor not
the republican donor class the [ __ ]
rich people
that's all they can concentrate on is oh
you're gonna raise taxes on rich people
how dare you how dare you raise taxes on
that's when when a republican says
they're going to raise your taxes they
mean how dare you raise taxes on rich
people
to make sure the middle class has what
they need and what they deserve and they
work hard for
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
we don't need to listen to that garbage
you just breeze right over it
right over it [ __ ] them
[ __ ] them
we create the narrative we
we amplify the narrative
and that's what we do and we keep doing
it and it's working it's working in
pennsylvania it's working in ohio
herschel walker is on his heels in
georgia he can't decide if he's going to
debate warnock or not which he he'll
never actually debate warnock and what i
mean by that is
like it's not really going to be a
debate even if they stand on stage
together
and they're like talking back and forth
it's not going to be much of a date but
debate let's be realistic here
right
it really isn't
it really isn't
oh
i love it i love it oh news we have bone
end of the week
it's friday you know what that means
bonehead of the week in the second hour
here on the tony michaels podcast gabe
sanchez will join us in the second hour
for bonehead of the week
i can't wait what a great bonehead
of the week poll we had this week and
you guys you guys did not disappoint
uh in your selection of bonehead of the
week i knew i knew it was probably
likely this person would win the
bonehead of the week
but i can't wait to get to that segment
gabe sanchez our our co-host and
executive producer will join us
for bonehead of the week in the second
hour you know that we do the bonehead of
the week in the second hour every single
friday
and you can vote on twitter so go follow
us on twitter at tonymichaelspod you can
also vote right here on youtube for
bonehead of the week every single week
just subscribe to the youtube channel
go to the community tab
and vote for bone head of the week every
single week because on friday for all
the new listeners in the second hour
because we do two hours a day
two hours
every day every goddamn one of them
monday through friday and on friday
in the second hour
we go through bonehead of the week
here's the cool thing about it
on sunday we re-air bonehead of the week
and we even make it available to be
downloaded on all your favorite
directories google spotify apple
whatever your favorite directory is you
can download the tony michaels podcast
seven
days
a week
seven days a week because on saturday we
have a best of that we release also that
you can download and watch here on
youtube so don't forget to subscribe
here on youtube
and check out all seven days of the tony
michael's podcast
i think we should get into the tweety
tweets and trendy trends because gabe's
not gonna join us till the second hour
so let's do this let's go to a quick
break when we get back
we're gonna watch some dark brandon
videos stick around
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
right after these messages
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capitol have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on january 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of congress who also helped with the
attempted coup pardon blanket will
protect you too pardon blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the usa don't delay and
get your part in blanket today for just
99.99 actual parting's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around for the break
a lot of video to get to today
a lot of topics to hit
some good news and some bad news for
ultra maga
[Music]
great news for dark brandon
dark brandon oh man that [ __ ] really
backfired on him didn't it
didn't it the dark brandon let's go bri
let's go brandon that really [ __ ]
backfired on him hard like really hard
just like everything else backfires on
him they're so excited they were
cheering yeah we're gonna take away
women's rights and then women are like
no you're [ __ ] not
no you're not [ __ ]
and you need to continue to lean into
that [ __ ] that [ __ ]
lean into democracy
that's what we need to do that's how we
solve these problems and by problems i
mean make these manga nazis crawl back
underneath their [ __ ] rocks
that's how you solve this problem
just like in the state of kansas they
did on tuesday
we got a lot of stuff trending here
today there's a lot of things going on
um we have
uh
the
uh
there's some news out of gaza apparently
um israel has launched a wave of air
strikes we have the jobs report that we
have to go through we also have
mago whining that that the government's
going to hire employees to
to do their job to make sure returns and
and rich people pay their taxes
why they whine at cpac they got another
[ __ ] cpac gonna have there's another
sea back
if i do they do how many of these did
they do a week
and the orange mussolini jesus and the
hungarian hitler are apparently keynote
speakers there jesus christ uh larry
kudlow again he's got his head up his
ass mark meadow has flipped on trump
apparently lindsey graham is really
upset that the democrats are having
legislative wins in the senate
and let's see what else do we have
something about charlie crist
i don't know some other things ron
desantis of course is in the news i want
to show you a video from
the
state attorney that he
that he fired he suspended because he
wouldn't he wouldn't be a fascist
soldier for him you won't be my brown
shirt you son of a [ __ ] so you're fired
you're out of here if you won't be a
fascist you don't get to be in my
government
well he's an elected official so that's
kinda that's kind of rich
so let's do this let's get to it because
we got to get to the [ __ ] list roundup
at the top of the hour so let's start
the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome to the [ __ ] list roundup the
part of the show where we round up all
the tweety tweets and the trendy trends
let's go surfing
how about that let's make this a little
bigger so we can see i've got some
videos some video i'd like to show you
uh here's first off uh hal sparks post
every sparklers like to join us welcome
to all the sparklers
hal should come over to the show what do
you think we should have hal on the show
here i've talked to hal on stuttering
john's podcast and also the january 6
select hearings but i should have hal on
the show here hal says i look forward to
a complete
completely hammered larry kudlow
slurring a heartfelt apology on the show
today yeah i doubt it um and here's the
reason why is because larry really stuck
his uh whiskey bottle in his mouth i
mean his foot in his mouth let's listen
kevin uh last minute
uh the consensus on wall street is 250
000
non-farm payroll jobs tomorrow you have
a quick thought
yeah initial claims are you know jumped
way up again they're in uh they're now a
recession signal initial claims are
unemployment insurance and so i think
we're looking at a number closer to 100.
i think that it's going to surprise way
on the downside
let's listen to what [ __ ] larry has
here to say and um
you still believe we're in a recession
oh i know we're in the recession
squid smacking your lips larry
put smack in your lips
leave her in the recession we are 100 in
a recession
so it's a terrific idea to raise taxes
in a recession right i mean
terrific idea a lot of common sense yeah
oh yeah it's a terrific idea to raise
taxes on rich people any old time larry
any old time eat the rich dummy yeah
it's it's it's a good idea raise taxes
on the wealthiest americans any old time
i mean for me i don't know about you out
there but for me that's good i'm great
with it
that's fantastic this is really [ __ ]
stupid a hundred thousand jobs so listen
this is what they're saying on fox
business of all [ __ ] places geez you
thought fox news was a big [ __ ] lie
fox business
fox business is saying oh yeah well
we're gonna create a hundred thousand
jobs and um that means we're a hundred
percent in a recession
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
how is even a hundred thousand jobs even
the even the [ __ ] the projection of
250 000 jobs how is that even an
indicator that we're in a recession
these people are [ __ ] boneheads and
they're [ __ ] lying to you and what
really pisses me off more than anything
is that not that just fox business is
buying into this [ __ ] garbage is that
the mainstream media buys this [ __ ] hook
line sinker cause larry kudlow said so
[ __ ] him he didn't know a goddamn thing
you know how i done i know that stupid
piece of [ __ ] doesn't know a goddamn
thing you know how i know he worked for
trump
in like the second half of the
administration he wasn't even trump's
first pick
he was the [ __ ] d team
get the [ __ ] out of here with larry
kudlow and fox business give me a break
fox business my ass they don't know
their they don't know [ __ ] business
if it would [ __ ] sit on their face
give me a break
recession
oh god damn they screamed and yelled and
pounded the table and they were pissed
off
about inflation for months years oh gas
prices the price of this the price of
that oh it's so expensive in our economy
and i was like well the opposite of
inflation is recession
and if they keep drawing up interest
rates and costing the middle class money
it just might may affect demand which
will draw us into i don't know a
recession
so even if we get to a recession which
we will recess eventually folks that's
how capitalist economies go
they inflate they recess they inflate
they recess it's a cycle
this is how this [ __ ] works where the
[ __ ] are you people been the last 125
years
but here's the thing
if really what they wanted to stop
inflation then they were rooting for
recession
and now they're acting like recessions
bad and they're gonna they're gonna as
root for inflation [ __ ] you hold them
accountable everywhere you go
everywhere you [ __ ] go because not
only did dark brandon add 520
28 000 jobs to the u.s economy
unemployment dropped it [ __ ] dropped
to three and a half percent
and on top of that crude crude oil is
now below ninety dollars a barrel which
is the first time since russia
invaded ukraine and the murderous
dictator vladimir putin has committed
war crimes and we said we're not buying
your oil because of it so we had to go
somewhere else and it took a little bit
for the world to get back on track when
they told russia to [ __ ] off
what is so complicated about this
nothing so hold them accountable when
you're out there engaging in your
democracy and you're talking to your
community members have that strategic
outrage hell come here
get the strategic outrage and go project
that [ __ ] into the world
put it on them [ __ ] yeah let's do it
give them the strategic outrage that we
need to
stop stop with the [ __ ] noise on the
right the lies the [ __ ] we don't
need that garbage liberalism is not weak
liberalism is the is the voice of
strength in this country do you know how
hard it is i know you folks know how
hard democracy is
you know how hard it is to get an entire
country behind one goddamn idea
and everyone agree on it that's a
[ __ ] difficult feat
it's a [ __ ]
democracy is not easy authoritarianism
fascism is easy that's the that's the
weak standpoint i mean you just select
one dumb [ __ ] to tell you what
to do and how to think who you can and
can't marry
what a woman can and can't do with her
body what you can and can can't learn in
school what truth what's truth what's
lies
yeah that's [ __ ] easy when one
person's telling you all that
[ __ ] ridiculous absolutely ridiculous
well we got one person fighting for our
democracy that's for sure and it's dark
brandon
i love all this dark brandon stuff
uh and i come across there's a lot of
memes out there but this this video here
holy [ __ ] this video here that i found
boy it puts it all together with a
ribbon on top let's listen
[Music]
you are dead
[Music]
[Music]
to all those of you who voted for
president trump there's no way out
[Music]
oh my god
i don't know who made this or who did
this i'm not sure but thank you so very
much for putting this together
spread that [ __ ] around the internet
like herpes [ __ ] them
i put it on instagram i put it on
facebook i put it over on tic tac i just
thought let's spread this around the
internet this is fantastic you talk
about [ __ ] in their cereal when they
came up with the let's go brandon i
thought calling them let's go brandon
nazis was going to be a good you know
good idea that'll work that'll help out
but this dark brandon stuff is a whole
another [ __ ] level
a whole another level
because dark brandon strikes again as
gave my co-host gabe sanchez tweets this
morning dark brandon strikes again
uh as brian tyler cohen tweets breaking
the economy added 528 000 jobs in july
obliterating the expectations the
unemployment rate dropped to a historic
low
of three and a half percent
are you still wondering why there's
there's uh help wanted signs all over
your town the reason why there's help
wanted signs all over your town is
because they're desperate for labor and
they wanna they want to sell your labor
for cheap and you ain't having it and
the reason why is because the economy is
good and there's places to walk your
labor someplace else folks
simple as that
that's how it works
and they're gonna [ __ ] and scream and
yell about rich people
the rich of the rich of us
the one percent getting their taxes
raised so we can have this inflation
reduction act
oh boy i bet that's just gonna play
really well i bet if we do a good enough
job to message that thing we the people
do a good enough job at messaging that i
bet that'll go over just like
overturning roe v wade
ben mizella says he has this great
dark brandon mimi says dark brandon said
let there be jobs
and so it was
528 000 new jobs created doubling
expectations
[Laughter]
they're [ __ ] fantastic
they're fantastic the memes are great
spread them
around the internet okay let's see what
else oh i want to go to this video here
speaking of ron desantis
we were talking about rhonda santos
earlier this is um and warren warren is
his name andrew warren
i think i got that right i don't know
it's friday i'm not going to look it up
i don't have gabe right here with me
right now he's going to come in the
second hour so yeah
i'll just make it up as i go
andrew warren he's the uh state attorney
that uh ron desantis suspended for not
enforcing ron desantis fascist
unconstitutional bigoted laws he said no
[ __ ] you now he kind of he kind of uh
you know i i said translation [ __ ] ron
desantis that was my translation of it
he had a little better way of putting it
let's listen
i haven't even looked at the order yet
because i woke up to do my job today and
that's exactly what i did now i've heard
it contains a lot of conjecture and lies
and just based on the governor's track
record with unconstitutional orders i
have a feeling that this is going to be
just as unconstitutional as the 15-week
ban abortion the anti-protest law and a
dozen other things that the governor
signed
the governor's trying to overthrow the
results of a fair and free election
two of them actually
and people need to understand
this isn't the governor trying to
suspend one elected official this is the
governor trying to overthrow democracy
here in hillsborough county
boom
boom you hear that messaging you hear
that it's leaking down folks
they're taking our cues
they're taking our cues as they know
that we are not going to put up with
fascism no matter what we will stand
behind them on their messaging when they
throw a punch we will be right there
with them
they know it they're starting to get it
and we need to do more of it
and we gotta have strategic outrage and
we have to stay pissed and we gotta go
[ __ ] vote and engage in your ballot
this guy knows it he's like yep they're
standing behind me they're standing
behind me because here's the thing what
happens with like ron desantis donald
trump greg abbott all these [ __ ]
fascists carrie lake jd vance all these
[ __ ] [ __ ] boxes
dr oz
herschel walker the one thing they know
is no matter how vile they get no matter
how many how much lies they tell
they know that the tail tail is always
going to be there to wag the dog
democrats have always been so scared of
offending everyone so scared of
offending everyone so scared of saying
the wrong thing
when they're telling the [ __ ] truth
just tell the truth
tell it raw [ __ ] take that goddamn
truth out and smack people in the face
with it
and live with it let's move on
and if we stand behind them and we get
behind people like this warren the state
attorney down in florida
about around his messaging you goddamn
right will win
this is another [ __ ] stupid
boneheaded move in the state of florida
as ron desantis is running for governor
another boneheaded move
because now here this person is
suspended
who was a state elected state official
as a state attorney in hillsborough
county now being suspended he can say
whatever the [ __ ] he wants now
what a boneheaded mood by ron desantis
what a boneheaded move and if you're a
pro-democracy person in florida
even if you're not a pro-democracy
person in florida you can help out
campaigns in florida make ron desantis
pay for this son of a [ __ ] make him pay
for his [ __ ] up here just like in the
state of kansas the legislator wanting
to take away rights away from women
because roe was overturned
they said
no
no and they made them pay for it on
tuesday
we have to make them pay
for these mistakes they're making just
like lindsey graham i'm gonna get to
that
going against the inflation reduction
act just like all these republican
senators win against the pact act and
[ __ ] on veterans we gotta make them pay
for this [ __ ]
and warren's showing you the road map of
howard to make ron desantis pay
for this dumb [ __ ] decision he made
to suspend warren
for not for not enforcing his fascist
bigoted unconstitutional laws let's
by finish those letters saying that you
wouldn't prosecute abortion cases or
enforce bans on uh
pre-assignment surgeries
so again i didn't see the governor's
press conference
the circus whatever he put out there but
i know if you want to talk about the
abortion ban
when i became state attorney i put my
hand on the bible and i swear to uphold
the us and the florida constitution and
under the florida constitution the
15-week abortion ban is unconstitutional
and it's not just me saying that it is a
court of law that has said that the
governor's bill has already been thrown
out now it's subject to other appeal but
while the governor is hoping that the
supreme court ignores the law in florida
i'm the one upholding the law i'm the
one protecting people's rights i'm the
only one at this moment who's actually
making sure that we are following the
law in hillsborough county
boom
follow his lead
follow his lead pro-democracy people in
florida support his message get behind
his message and bury ron desantis that's
what you have to do
that is what you have to do because we
can't let fascists take over because
they are look at this
mike mike sington um has some pictures
he says pretend president
pretend president trump has pretense
summit with victor orban the hungarian
hitler i added that part at pretend
white house in new jersey look at this
[ __ ] this is this is the same house you
remember when he won and he was trying
to make it look like he was already in
the white house so he was standing
outside this stupid [ __ ] house
in uh in new jersey
and here here he is standing outside the
house again
um
with victor over look oh this the stupid
[ __ ] thumbs up
the stupid fight there's there's orange
mussolini jesus and the hungarian hitler
just like in the 1930s in europe there
it is folks oh they meet again huh
it almost looks like i'm not you know
victor orban is wearing an orange tie
you notice that
do you notice that victor orban is
wearing an orange tie and he kind of he
kind of made himself look more orange
do you see that
he looks more orange than the cheeto
dust mobster here
oh he put on his [ __ ] cheeto tie
holy [ __ ] i wonder if he had his cheeto
dust knee pads on too [ __ ] the hungarian
hitler and [ __ ] them for letting him
speak at cpac
if you're if you're still wondering why
they fantasize
over these these
these dictators
well
it's right there right there
i'm speaking of
speaking of fascist
and fascist and fascists who love
hungarian hitler
tucker carlson he really
he really stepped in it yesterday when
he went after jon stewart and i'll show
you that video uh adam parkamenko says
it would be terrible if thousands of you
retweeted this might as touch tweet
retweeted a video uh the time jon
stewart brutally humiliated tucker
carlson on his show is worth a watch it
is worth a watch i can't i don't know
man you know what it's friday why not we
got we got time let's go watch this
video
uh let's go watch this video here let's
watch this is crossfire and i don't know
i think this is like 1990
19 or 2002 or some [ __ ] i don't know
let's look
welcome back to crossfire we're talking
to jon stewart who's just lecturing us
on our moral inferiority john you're
bumming us out tell us what do you think
of the bill o'reilly vibrator story no
i'm sorry i don't
i'm here to confront you because we need
help
from the media and they're
hurting us ah that was 2004.
it's too almost 20 years ago it was 18
years ago
and here's jon stewart saying the media
is hurting us
and jon stewart not only not only saved
a lot of lives by helping the first
responders from 9 11 the survivors
get their health care paid for through
congress get that
reinstated but he also did
he stood behind the pack now
unselfishly with those veterans used his
microphone to get people to pay a
[ __ ] attention
and he did it in the right way and folks
again this goes back to language
jon stewart stood in front of a
microphone on public television
pointed to the capitol and called
republicans those [ __ ]
those [ __ ] that is a huge
huge
paradigm shift in our politics it really
is i know it seems like ah well what's
the big deal he he did it that's what
jon stewart would say
but
the political body responded
that's the most important part here
about strategic outrage we talked with
david bender and rachel bitterkoffer
about these facts this week
about how the political body in this
country the the
earth is shifting
underneath us
and the moment that jon stewart stood in
front of a microphone and called
republicans
despicable vile veteran hating
republicans
those [ __ ] when he said that i
don't know anything he called them that
three four times in that press
conference
and democracy and the people responded
and what happened was the senators
had to change their vote especially
after we watched ted cruz and josh
hawley celebrate celebrate
that veterans didn't get their health
care that they deserve and earned
and the country went yep john stewart's
right they are a bunch of [ __ ]
look at those [ __ ] bumping fist
that's it folks and it's only because we
took the messaging and we ran with it
and the message was simple from jon
stewart but listen to this message he
here here has for tucker carlson i made
a special effort to come on the show
today because i have mentioned uh this
show as being
uh bad
it's not so much that it's bad as it's
hurting america
so i i wanted to come here today
and say wait wait just don't let me
i guess maybe this was the first time
when a tucker carlson show was hurting
america now his show is continuing to
hurt america oh jesus i just want what i
wanted to tell you guys yeah just
stop
stop stop stop stop hurting america
i watch your show every day and it kills
me i can tell you a lot it's so oh it's
so painful to watch your partisan um
what do you call it hacks
wait shot wait
you have a responsibility to the public
discourse and you failed
miserably i think you're a good comedian
i think your lectures are boring you're
the show that leads into me is puppets
making crank phone calls
what is wrong with you it's someone who
watches your show and cannot take it
anymore
i just can't fail
miserably i think you need to go to one
now this is theater i mean it's it's
obvious
how old are you 35 and you wear a bow
tie yeah i do i do so
and you wear a bow tie
oh my god thank you jon stewart i think
he deserves the
presidential
uh medal of freedom just for saying that
[ __ ] to tucker carlson back in 2004.
here is uh tucker carlson here's the
response the reason why the internet
responded
is because uh tucker carlson on white
privilege tonight on faux news um said
this about jon stewart what an idiot
that's jon stewart the famous john
stewart looks like a homeless mental
patient
he's shrieking and disheveled and very
short he's very pissed off at fascists
like you
that's that's what's going on here
tucker tuckham's
that's what's going on here is he's
pissed off at fascists like you
really short too short to date
was he always that short
what happened what happened what is that
john's does he have a beard is his hair
turned gray
is that jon stewart is that the co you
notice how he does this stupid [ __ ]
and they buy this [ __ ] hook like can you
imagine sitting having to watch this
whole thing for like an hour i can't
even hardly get through a 20-second clip
jesus
where's he been the last seven years
if you know let us know
we want answers you know where he's been
do you know where he's been tucker the
last seven years he's been he's been
making sure that congress does their
[ __ ] job
with first responders from 911 survivors
the surviving people left
that congress wouldn't reinstate their
[ __ ] health care that they that we we
the people should be giving them
for serving their [ __ ] country on
that day in september
do you know where else he was tucker
you little [ __ ] you bow tie little
[ __ ] he was at washington
with those veterans on the steps of the
capitol
jon stewart just didn't show up
when the packed act didn't pass
you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
jon stewart was there the entire [ __ ]
time with those veterans and that's how
you know it was a selfless act because
jon stewart didn't get in front of a
microphone
and use his celebrity until he had to
you [ __ ]
that's when he used his celebrity that's
when he used his microphone that's when
he used his amplifier is when he had to
when those pieces of vile [ __ ] those
[ __ ]
as jon stewart said
those [ __ ]
that's when he used his microphone
when he had to
to get fascists like you in line you
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
sorry i had to get that off my chest
oh tucker carlson you are a piece of
[ __ ]
garbage
did you see the alex jones verdict
yesterday that's another story alex in
the alex jones trial
uh 4.1 million dollars was awarded
in damages actual damages to the
families in that suit
um
after
after the decision came down though i
noticed this in the courtroom
that the lawyers were winking at each
other watch this so is there are there
any you expect any changes to the charge
questions that were given to me before
no your honor
i don't think so okay then that'll be
pretty easy we'll work on that anything
else
all right so we'll see you tomorrow
morning thank you very much everyone
okay so this is where they're adjourning
the jury has left after the judge has
read the the judgment of 4.1 million
dollars being awarded from alex jones to
the sandy hook families in this case now
this is just the actual damages not the
punitive damages they've reconvened this
morning about the punitive damages
and the punitive damages in texas
apparently
the statute is that they can only be
twice as much as the actual damages so
the actual damages are 4.1 which means
the punitive damages even if the jury
comes back and is like ah we're gonna
award the family 100 million dollars the
state of texas the law is that that alex
jones only has to pay
double
the punitive or
up to 750 000 which it'll go over 750
000 pretty damn quick
um so that means you know he's on the
hook for about 12.3 million dollars at a
maximum here in this case
in this specific case he also has
another case in texas he has another
case in connecticut and he's on the hook
for all the fees for the lawyers and
fines and [ __ ] where he has
not done the correct thing where the
judge has fined him
which is i think another one and a half
million dollars in this case alone so
he's gonna pay like almost between 13
and 14 million dollars on this case here
in austin texas
so keeping that in mind
his attorneys here know this right they
know what's going to happen
now that they've now that they
have done the math
on
um this judgment watch what happens when
the lawyers
look at each other here as the as the
judge
leaves the courtroom because it isn't
until the judge leaves the courtroom
that they signal each other watch
the judge gets up to leave the courtroom
they look at each other
wink
wink
they wink
he winks
and the reason why he winked is because
here's the thing even though this is
probably not as
big of a settlement as you would hope
for
for the families of sandy hook not just
not just to get it alex jones right not
just to [ __ ] with him not just to get in
his money get in his pocket and bankrupt
him
which he claims he's already bankrupt
but to actually give that family the
damages that they deserve that that alex
jones and infowars has caused them a lot
of them had to [ __ ] move change their
[ __ ] names and all kinds of crazy ass
[ __ ] that would cost people all kinds of
money
but the attorneys know that this isn't
going to destroy alex that he's still
going to have money left over to pay
them wink wink wink
winking at each other i noticed that as
like you son of a [ __ ]
i posted that over on the podcast page
and i think it's important i think it's
important and also yesterday dick cheney
released a video
darth vader
uh oh
what did dick cheney say
is he gonna shoot someone in the face i
don't know let's find out
in our nation's 246-year history there
has never been an individual who is a
greater threat to our republic than
donald trump he tried to steal the last
election using lies and violence to keep
himself in power after the voters had
rejected him
he was a coward a real man wouldn't lie
to his supporters
well a real man wouldn't lie to his
supporters are we really hearing this
from dick cheney a real man wouldn't lie
to his are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me
why do you think we were in a [ __ ]
war in afghanistan and iraq and the
verse please this guy lied his ass off
lied his ass off but you know let's go
on he's bashing trump here so we gotta
like it i guess he lost his election and
he lost big
i know it he knows it and deep down i
think most republicans know it
lynn and i are so proud of liz for
standing up for the truth
doing what's right honoring her oath to
the constitution when so many in our
party are too scared to do so
liz is fearless she never backs down
from a fight there is nothing more
important she will ever do
than lead the effort to make sure donald
trump is never again near the oval
office
and she will succeed
i am dick cheney i proudly voted for my
daughter i hope you will too
i'm liz cheney and i approve this
message
she's liz cheney and she approves this
message because liz cheney knows one
thing
she wants to take back over her party
that's what she wants um you know people
are saying that she's not gonna win in
wyoming
they keep saying that i have people
personally telling me no there's no
[ __ ] way liz cheney will win in
wyoming and i say i think you're full of
[ __ ]
i think you're full of [ __ ]
i think the polls have been wrong this
entire time i think the polls are
outdated and antiquated how they do the
polls where they do the polls who does
the polls is antiquated polls could work
i'm not saying polls can't be right
but the polls have been wrong
if you look at it i mean just here in
missouri everyone was terrified that
eric greitens would win
the polls showed that eric greitens had
a chance to win he didn't even break 20
percent
the polls showed that the kansas
referendum
would go in the way of the fascist in
some of the polls
65 and i think is what the result was
not even [ __ ] close
not even [ __ ] close
and some of these other primaries the
same thing so i'm not going to believe
the polls in wyoming
i'm not i'm not going to believe it
i think there's a different a different
political environment that we're dealing
with and pollsters just haven't figured
that out yet that this is a completely
different environment
that you can't just pull democrats
republicans and independents like
there's no such thing anymore
there's no [ __ ] such thing there are
pro-democracy people and they're our
fascists
that that that's what we have that's the
that's our division in this country
you you're you're for democracy or
you're against it
it's not like oh abortion or oh high
taxes or federalist anti-federalist like
it's not that it's we're not there
that's not the political environment
that we have
we have pro-democracy people in this
country and we have fascists in this
country
and that's what's happening
and they're not polling
with that in mind
they're just not
they keep listening to the lies
of these boneheads
and until they straighten up the media
they straighten up and stop listening to
this nonsense that they keep listening
to we're going to keep doing this stupid
[ __ ] over and over
and over again i want to go to um
real quickly before we go to bone head
of the week um here's the story
let's see if i can find
uh
um there's a story out that mark meadows
has turned on trump possibly here it is
here's the video i actually think that
mark mendes has probably turned on trump
for a while now
and the reason why is because that
contempt charge just hasn't stuck at the
department of justice hmm i wonder why
but mark meadows goes out every once in
a while and sips for trump well that's a
sign and he doesn't simp hard for him
it's like uh you know he kind of lightly
dances around that he loves trump
well that's his public view because he
doesn't want trump to know that he's
turned against him
well let's listen continue to see it you
know a nine-year sentence uh
for miss greiner it's it's sad we want
her to come home but now we're training
uh her for a prisoner that actually was
convicted of conspiracy who killed
american citizens see this is the thing
anytime one of these fascists say but
they mean all the [ __ ] i just said i
don't actually believe
brittany griner being sentenced to nine
years is oh that's a tragedy
but
[ __ ] her
we don't want her to come home that's
what he's saying you know it sets a very
bad precedent i can tell you uh donald
trump when he was in the white house was
able to get more hostages released and
back home without having to kind of pay
the price why because the leaders knew
he was strong and he was willing to back
it up so here you go here's mark meadows
pretending to be a trump supporter here
as he's turning on him at the department
of justice which is a normal thing
like that that's a that's a normal thing
that's not something that's abnormal
right i mean because
mark meadows in the department of
justice doesn't really want trump to
think
that he's turned on him now trump's
legal team
has
surmised that he's turned on him and the
reason why
is because they've told uh donald trump
apparently to stop communications with
mark meadows and a few others but mark
meadows specifically
and when your council here's glenn uh
glenn's tweet of it it says new cnn
reporting trump has has been
specifically been counseled to cut
cut contact with his former white house
chief of staff mark meadows watch the
dominoes begin to fall
we are on the road to accountability
through though the road is long unpaved
and filled with treacherous potholes
it's coming and that's that's what
glenn's been trying to say this whole
time that yes this is going to be held
accountable but it's going to take a
while because the amount of evidence
that there is is ridiculous and the
amount of evidence that they're going to
have to convince the grand jury of that
this is a slam dunk and they really want
to go into court with this being a slam
dunk seeing that it's the cheeto dust
mobster
so glenn is right here i think this is a
big sign a huge sign when donald trump's
counsel is trying to convince him to
stop talking to mark meadows because
mark meadows is using that information
against you demi in a criminal trial not
not civil case not the january 6 select
committee folks
we're talking about a grand jury for the
department of justice in washington dc
for criminal charges for january 6.
justice
is coming
so let's do this while justice works
let's focus on our democracy
and let's engage in it
and let's do that
by going to bone end of the week right
after the break here gabe sanchez will
join us for bonehead of the week don't
go anywhere bone of the week right after
this break
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome oh welcome welcome welcome
welcome back to the show thanks for
sticking to the break
friday second hour gabe is joining us
now
for bonehead
of
the
week
of the week
boom our favorite segment our favorite
to the show gabe welcome to the show
we're gonna do bone end of the week we
had a lot of bonuses oh boy did we boy
were there some boom
headed [ __ ] this week holy [ __ ]
i think we should just get right into it
and do bonehead of the week what do you
think let's do it let's do it
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to this edition of bonehead of
the week like we said this week has been
bone-headed as [ __ ] it's been a great
week though yeah no tons of very
revealing
right great news for democracy
we had the kansas uh turned down uh the
the amendment to
take away the rights of women and
liberty and bodily autonomy from women
in kansas they said [ __ ] no not just no
but [ __ ] no yep to that amendment which
is great um there were some great uh
outcomes for some of these primaries i
believe uh going forward this proves
that there are people still out there
that are confident in our democracy they
want to participate and engage in our
democracy and i think that's important
but also we had some side drama
side drama
of like the pact act john stewart um
in the last week and into this week
passing the helping getting that across
the finish line we have a couple of
those senators on the bonehead list for
that and then we have some drama down in
florida but also this alex jones trial
holy [ __ ] gabe what do you think about
this stuff it is look you know we talked
about it yesterday on the show like you
know how like the ability to hear you
know in the courtroom and stuff and we
were comparing it to the amber uh heard
johnny depp trial like you know the the
quality of the production there is right
there they knew what was happening they
had two celebrities that were going
head-to-head that were saying you know
he said this and she said that and
everyone was interested when it came
time to this alex jones trial nobody
could have anticipated the [ __ ] that was
going to happen
little fingers here you had you know
almost fights there you had revealing
text messages over here like yeah even
even even seditious sexting between
roger stone
and
uh alex jones kind of reveal we haven't
seen it yet we haven't seen and i don't
know if we do we want to see the
intimate well i don't know you know
depending on who you are yeah we'll
definitely definitely jump into that
because alex jones is another person
that was on bonehead of the week but
yeah that was a whole that whole court
case i don't think anyone expected
anything to come of that outside of like
we're gonna decide what the amount is
for this that what had already been
decided as like he was guilty of
defamation and now what is the actual
financial amount they will be awarded
right and we have some news we have some
news on that too but let's go to the
boneheads here we have senator rand paul
he's been on our list a lot
as well as senator ted cruz i mean again
we say this all the time like i feel
like every week we get here we're like
ah these [ __ ] could be here every
single week oh yeah these guys these
guys set up camp and they're like
they're like on the bench ready to go
and they're like put me in coach put me
in i'm ready do you think do you think
they're in like
the senate gym and they're like how do
we get on bone into the week yeah yeah
well i mean
ted cruz is you know he's like trying to
dribble a basketball he's like how do i
get on bonehead of the week how do i get
on bonehead of the week you know but
really these two senators are on the
bone of the week because of the pact act
right like in the response to it their
own individual responses to what
happened they've got them on this list
this week right and one really the the
senator rand paul it was more about his
response on the floor right um tell the
folks about that as i find the clip here
of rand paul on the floor right so rand
paul tried to have the paul amendment
added to the pact act which got
overwhelmingly
down voted it was 70 to 90 or seven to
90 is what the end result so 90 saying
they don't want this amendment in there
which would basically uh change the
amount of funds that were given to
to help
fund the pact act and it was to lower uh
foreign aid to different countries
so that they could help pay off the pact
act
and uh it was you know marcia blackburn
mike lee ron johnson like all of the
people who have either you know they
have no purpose they they serve no
purpose in the senate they've attempted
to
you know how about you define what a
woman is hey we should try to get uh
mike pence these fake electors like all
of these people are terrible bone-headed
human beings so it i'm not surprised at
all that these were the seven people
that voted for this dumb
uh amendment that thankfully got voted
down right well you know every time rand
paul speaks whether it's on the floor on
the record or in a committee or even
when you say on the floor is that
because he's like a mop head well it
could be like you know that that's a
good point but when he speaks i i want
to be his neighbor more and more and
more
i think every day people hear him speak
and they're like
really like especially for something
like this like the things that he says
in this moment to be like i'm right and
here is why i'm right
more people are probably like yeah i
wouldn't mind being his neighbor as well
you know
really i really would like to be this
guy's neighbor like every day be his
neighbor let's listen to rand paul here
trying to tell us now that the cdc is
right and asthma that veterans has
is just asthma it's no big deal gabe
care of our veterans and keep our
country strong
this bill puts our economy though at
risk by creating presumptions of service
connection for the most common
availments this [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
again again he's acting like he's acting
he's acting like he's doing the gas
price the gas price thing like oh this
is going to affect the economy gets like
who gives a [ __ ] right people are dying
because of their service to our country
well he's also i mean like he's like i'm
you know he's he's attempting to make
that whole i'm a doctor argument and
it's like no you [ __ ] dumbass you're
not uh and if anyone i would say we
don't have time to dig into this show
but if anyone's interested just google
rand paul
is he an actual doctor and the things
you will read and find out are not
surprising but also here's what i'll
tell you is um
go to twitter and copy or do some
screenshots of
googling is rand paul an actual doctor
that'd be fantastic
tag us in them that would be great let's
listen
for example
this legislation creates a presumption
of service connection for vietnam
veterans for hypertension
but according to the cdc fifty percent
of men and forty four percent of women
in the united states have hypertension
you know you could do a what was that
with almost every single clip of these
[ __ ] boneheads because he's like the
cdc according to the cdc like what what
was that like really honestly now you're
going to believe in the cdc right that's
the thing that you believe them
everything else all the million people
that was killed there in the pandemic
mask vaccines [ __ ] all that [ __ ] [ __ ]
that nonsense you're like well maybe the
monkey pox this like cases of polio
we've seen come up now like everything
the cdc says about all these other
diseases and all these health uh issues
he goes nah [ __ ] it everything
he's like hypertension and asthma
those are the ones we should listen to
them about
everything he says it makes me want to
be more and more neighborly
to rand paul i mean really it's like
will you be my neighbor over and over i
kind of now have this visual of rand
paul as
the like evil mr rogers and he's like
will you be my neighbor and it was like
[ __ ] yeah i'll be your neighbor like
dark rogers kind of yeah like a dark
like a dark rogers you know and you know
he sits down and he's like will you be
my neighbor and everyone ever all the
kids are like yeah okay
you goddamn right we would let's finish
this bone end more than 60 percent of
people over the age of 60 have
hypertension
in total the cdc estimates that 106
estimates that 116 million americans
have hypertension
the legislation also creates a
presumption of service connection for
global war on terror veterans for asthma
the cdc estimates that one in 12 people
have asthma which is approximately 25
million americans do you think when he
went to his staffer and he was like hey
can you go give me some cdc numbers on
this this and this they're like what was
that
yeah they're like why and he was well
i'm trying to make a point a point about
what well i need to prove how asthma is
a way in which i can make this whole
like pack act not really go further it's
like they i'm sure like the intern of
the aid was like
why why would you do that also it's like
the same argument because he's trying to
be like oh 25 million people like are
you either are you trying to argue that
that's a lot of people or a little
amount of people and then it goes this
same argument that people made during
covid which is like well only like one
percent of people are there or like
affected this way and it's like yeah but
one percent of a population that is
nearly 350 million people that's a lot
of people when you're talking about like
the debts right
so whenever you or you know whatever the
percentage the low percentage that they
would claim it's like even one person
dying from this thing is bad right why
are we accepting any greater number than
one
that's [ __ ] crazy well here's here's
the mop head again now this has to do
with the finland sweden
membership which he voted for yeah in
the long run the only one he had no what
i mean what he had to give his two cents
what do you say well yeah well let's
listen
my reservation merely reasserts his
reservation nearly that's it okay i'm
done i don't i don't even need it i
don't even need any more of this clip i
don't need anymore what is it all of
these republicans lauren bobert and all
these other people are like oh we're
gonna let finland and sweden into nato
why would we do that you know why that
makes no sense you know but after a
while these people that were you know
have typically historically been neutral
you know they're like we don't want
involved they're like okay
we're going to now be involved because
the world is [ __ ] up and we need to
actually like take a stance and
republicans are like no
whoa whoa
you want to be you want to like pro
democracy what are you right no what are
you doing dude no so yeah well
again he's
putting some sort of amendment on the
floor that's not going to get accepted
this is all and he voted for it in the
first place this is all to get on fox
news
he does the [ __ ] all the time what josh
hawley voted against the bill the only
one to vote against it so he could get
on tucker carlson's show like literally
that's the reason i even said this on
centering john's podcast i said look the
reason why josh hawley voted against
this thing isn't because he you know
this thing that thing this it literally
he was like well if i don't know him i'm
the only one vote no putin's little
puppet putin's little you know fellatio
will let me on his show on white
privilege tonight with tucker carlson
he'll bring me on and i'll get to talk
about putin how great putin is because
tucker loves putin and that's why he
voted against it it's all for the fox
news clips it's all you know the other
thing that makes me think of is when
they're done as soon as they're done
with the vote there are cameras always
ready in like the rotunda area right
right right on that floor and they're
all waiting to be like all right can we
get you in for an interview so and so is
live right now and wants to ask you
about the vote
but the acoustics and the echo you can
hear it during the interview it is very
like very powerful the way that the
audio from your s your your talking will
carry throughout the rest of the
the uh outside of the chambers in the
rotunda area
and i always think like walking through
if i were to ever walk through when one
of those interviews are happening like
one
saying [ __ ] back
to echo and overtake their interview but
two like people walking by and having to
listen to the dumb
stupid [ __ ] that these people say just
to get on fox news he's like oh i voted
against them entering nato because it's
like
that's you that's it why would you even
why why why why are you trying to be
it's just it's a pain in the ass to
listen to but i can only imagine what
it's like for people who are actually
inside of me like i just wanted to have
like two moments to think to myself
without hearing rand paul or josh hawley
[ __ ] blabber on about why they voted
against this thing that they should have
voted for right well it makes you again
want to be very neighborly with these
fun [ __ ] and uh speaking of
[ __ ] we have ted cruz there
could be like a gazillion reasons just
this week why ted cruz is on here but i
have a clip here i guess this was uh
from today or yesterday where they were
having an oversight um committee meeting
uh for fbi oversight with uh fbi
director ray
and ted cruz i guess gets out his
[ __ ] boot i've not seen this i
haven't watched this he gets a little
boot watch this
violent extremist militia well i will
self-report right now
that every day in the senate i wear my
boots
that have the gonzales battle flag on
the back of them
what the [ __ ]
so here you go again here you go at the
political theater to get on fox news
this [ __ ] takes he didn't take
his boot off he wore a different pair of
shoes in there he had a [ __ ] boot
ready to go
oh these boots are made for walking and
if anyone doesn't know oh my god you
know do you know what the gonzalez
battle flag is
no go ahead it does it's the dumb ass
well it's not dumb ass and it's dumb ass
in the response or in the aspect of of
of ted cruz that come and take it that's
what that battle flag says
so that's what he's trying to push he's
like every day i wear these boots and on
the back it's the gonzalez battle flag
and on the gonzalez battle flag and says
come and take it which is the same [ __ ]
that he says on his mask whenever they
talk about [ __ ] guns whatever it
might be ted cruz is always saying come
and take it you want my gun come and
take it you want this liberty come and
take it you want these rights come and
take it and then he'll be like oh
actually uh yes go and take those rights
away from women and anyone who has a
marginalized community that's what ted
cruz says right they do he believes
[ __ ]
ted cruz is like threatening the
government he says come and take this
thing from me and then him as the
government says aha yes i will come and
take those things from you right right
like that's the hypocrisy of this party
and that is the hypocrisy of this
[ __ ] wish.com version of wolverine
well i was gonna play the fist bump but
i think this is as despicable as that is
uh i don't think anyone needs to see the
fist bump again where he i can only
imagine this oh and he had the shoe off
oh my god
the whole time
he said
i think if he's really wearing those
boots he had it on the whole time
up until the point of which he had to
talk or
he took it off as soon as he sat down
he's like well can't get up now because
i got one boot on one boot off
and he's like i'm just waiting for the
point where i can slam that boot down
and say i've got the gonzales battle
flag on my boot
doesn't really make your point any
stronger yeah such an idiot let's watch
let's watch this bonehead do this bone
edit thing one more time
um just because i think it's [ __ ]
stupid and hilarious violent extremist
militia well i will self-report right
now
that every day in the senate i wear my
boots
that have the gonzales battle flag on
the back of them
did you see mike lee behind him he's
like he's such a dumb book yeah look at
mike lee here he's like oh my god did he
practice this mike lee's thinking is in
his mind
how many times did this idiot practice
this before he got it right oh my god
and michael he's like put your [ __ ]
boot back on you now somebody's like
that's what that smell was i was
wondering what smelled like
[ __ ] baby [ __ ] wrapped in you know
whatever [ __ ]
dead possums ass oh my god it's like you
know it's like an anchorman it's like it
smells like bigfoot's dick you know
that's just that whole that whole line
the whole lines of the jokes of the
throw away like one-liners from that
moment where he comes out with the
[ __ ]
uh sex panther cologne that's probably
what
ted cruz's boot smells like
and as well as his feet
oh
nasty that's nasty
speaking of nasty
is a nasty nasty senator he's a nasty
[ __ ] well let's uh let's go to
another nasty son of a [ __ ] uh governor
ron desantis he's our alpha guck of the
week alpha cuck
why did he get alpha cuck what happened
here with ron desantis i mean i can only
imagine but what what's the what's the
deal with ron desantis gabe
well uh you know we've got these whole
rights being taken away in florida and
then he decides that it was the uh it
was the county attorney who was it again
i uh yeah i forget the name but he's
he's like a state attorney right and
he's and he's he's uh
suspending the state attorney uh recount
has a video here let's see if
we can get some
a tampa prosecutor right took his stance
against criminalizing abortion because
this person was like yeah
we're not going to do this thing that
you want to do you [ __ ] fascist
dictator right he's deciding not to
enforce the unconstitutional law that
rhonda's
women have rights
and they should be able to do what they
want with their own bodies and you
[ __ ] want to be trump 2.0 get your
[ __ ] grubby little hands out of these
women you know right well let's listen
to uh captain fascist here tell us why
he's a whiny little [ __ ]
the constitution of florida has vested
the veto power in the governor
not in individual state attorneys and so
when you flagrantly violate your oath of
office when you make yourself above the
law
you have violated your duty
you have neglected your duty and you are
displaying a lack of competence to be
able to reform those duties and so today
we are suspending
state attorney andrew warren effective
immediately
so now do trump
yeah now
trump this is one of those ron desantis
is one of those people i mean we saw it
before with the kids with masks on and
he was like don't wear the mask don't do
that don't this political theater
[ __ ]
but you look behind ron desantis right
he tells these people to be there
whether they're pro ron desantis and
fascism or they're like oh the [ __ ]
chief told me how to show up here
but these people behind him in suits and
also in their actual uh law enforcement
you know uniform
are there as like a sign of if you cross
me as governor i will [ __ ] you up right
and that is not how we do things in this
country you can't just say what a rule
is and then say if you do anything which
again right you're taking rights away
from women so the fact that this guy is
suspended for trying to
acknowledge that women should have these
rights and they should determine what
they should do with their own body as
opposed to ron desantis saying
if there's an abortion
i'm coming after you
and it's like one it's none of your
[ __ ] business dude why you guys are
also fascinated and obsessed with what
someone else does with their own body
and their own home with their own
just [ __ ]
bubble
freedom
this is exactly freedom it's ridiculous
it's absolutely ridiculous so ron
desantis stands in front of all these
people and he's just a [ __ ] cuck
right here's what yeah he is a cuck he
he's getting he gets cocked all the time
and the reason why he's going to get
cucked here is exactly what kansas
did to the referendum to try to take
away women's rights because if you
really look at the makeup of kansas
it feels really similar to the makeup of
the voters an electorate
like states like texas georgia florida
who seem really red
but on issues where i don't know someone
takes away an entire group of people's
liberty right
they they're not so [ __ ] red right
and i believe that in the american
people and in this democracy and that's
why i've been so confident about this as
long as we engage in our democracy
america is going to project this idea
that you can just take away [ __ ]
rights from a group of people like wait
a second what the [ __ ] are you talking
about and rather it's kansas rather it's
the dobbs case where the supreme court
overturns roe v wade or it's [ __ ]
hitler junior down in florida's ron
desantis trying to be a king fascist
down there trying to be like you said
trump 2.0
and trying to trying to run rough shot
over liberty freedom rights
and and just plain being un-american and
unpatriotic and he's the example of what
they want to do with with the united
states government yeah as a fascist
state that's the blueprint we've talked
about it a hundred times before
and uh you know ron desantis he deserves
i do want to add one more thing on there
yeah if you've noticed like in
california we've had cases kind of
rising in in terms of monkey pox
illinois has had cases florida has had
cases right uh just uh on thursday uh or
i think it was thursday that uh
that uh joe biden was uh he had
announced that there is now a state of
emergency around monkey pox right we are
a health emergency right and they are
taking the appropriate steps because we
do not want a covid lockdown you know
2.0 kind of situation happen where we've
got monkey pox spreading uh between
communities and people not doing
anything to make sure that they are
staying away from others
as well while they get treatment
now the benefit of having monkey pox
right now is that we do and we we can
treat it with the smallpox vaccine
and so ron desantis is saying no no no
no we're not doing this fear [ __ ] again
let me just make this clear this is not
fear [ __ ] this is just the appropriate
way in terms of how you handle a health
issue right we have the appropriate
steps and protocols we have someone who
is in office as a leader who's not going
to say not my responsibility or it'll
miraculous go away by easter or all you
got to do is shove light up your ass and
inject bleach we don't have someone like
that we have
is that the monkey box vaccine shove a
light up your eyes i think you know i
don't know if those things really work
for covid but trump might tell you that
that is how you treat monkey pots it
could be it could be now you know that's
a good point because we went through
this with a pandemic and it always
confused me because ron desantis if you
ask like you know what are you
politically he would say something
stupid like i'm a conservative which
he's not a conservative at all he's a
fascist but here's the thing the
conservative
of conservative person a conservative
leader or or a conservative government
would actually be in favor of things
that like you're talking about they'd be
like hey we need to make sure that this
isn't spreading we need to keep track of
it we need to do what we can do to make
sure people don't get disease because
this thing could kill people it can hurt
people it's a health issue
a liberal type of government be like and
you know let's just see what happens
yeah like it is what it is right it is
what it is you can't change it let's
just keep going about it and that's the
confusing part to me that's a confusing
part to me is they they
doing this type of dance around this
stuff where again it's not
you know
and i think me me you and david bender
talked about it the other day this isn't
really republican democrat anymore right
we're in we're in an age where these
things don't really mean the things that
they meant 10 15 years ago
and they're trying to use words and come
up with ways to describe
their political stance and the way they
want to govern with words that aren't
the same when it's just pure blooded
fascism that john desantis wants to have
and that's why
he's the applica because he's wants to
be king fascist down in florida now
we're fascist and and the last thing too
is a fascist will also make sure
to scrub out anyone else's voice
so when you have an audit that it was
like a few weeks ago or a month ago or
so you know uh was also covered when i
did the interview with dr eric feiglding
one of the things was the fact that
there was an audit in florida and they
did find out that you know
um
the there was manipulation with the data
that was coming out of florida to say
how many cases and debts there were
and that the whistleblower who was
actually running against matt gates in
his district this year
um
came forward and ron desantis was the
person who's like no no we're going to
arrest you you shouldn't have done that
you shouldn't have talked about this and
that is exactly what a dictator and a
fascist will try to do is they will
silence any voice that does not in
agreement with theirs if you don't
follow the cult if you don't follow our
regime and our voice on what we say then
we cast you out and we silence you
as a as a traitor
and that is not democracy
that is that is the opposite of
democracy
so um
if we can move to the dishonorable
mention because we we did alpha cuck
here right yeah yeah but the
dishonorable mention it kind of
i don't know it bleeds in with the
winner here oh yeah yeah they kind of a
chair right it's kind of a shared story
almost
so who is this dishonorable mention
because i i've never heard this name
before you know
he's not a name that you would probably
hear he is known
as a lawyer so for anyone watching right
now and listening this is uh andino
reynold he is the lawyer for alex jones
in this defamation trial that was
happening in texas so what is the f
stand board have we figured that out
this standpoint does it stand for
[ __ ] fernando what what's the what's
the uh well i tried to find what the f
stood for and i cannot find it couldn't
find it i didn't i did find i did find a
video though here um
and it might be
someone may
may have made a joke of this i couldn't
imagine who but this is so i think you
put it as a dm and the reason why is
because he kind of [ __ ] up in the
trial right well not in the trial so
much as in the evidence
and not really
you know staying on top of things right
and it created this moment in the alex
jones trial where alex jones is kind of
you know slapped in the face with
reality uh it was a beautiful moment oh
it is a beautiful moment it's beautiful
so let's watch and this goes to tell you
or this goes to show you earlier when we
were talking about how you know amber
hurt and johnny depp they had prepared
for this type of drama right this trial
was like oh yeah we'll give you a you
know a feed and you can watch into it
but nobody anticipated the type of [ __ ]
show
that was gonna come out of this thing
right well even law and crime here on
their youtube channel because they had
one camera in the room right and it
appeared there was another camera room
we've tried to determine who that camera
is and then there's the zoom camera
which is like the the courtroom record
camera right that they're broadcasting
on the courtroom's youtube channel who
knows maybe if there's somebody's doing
a documentary about alex it could be it
could be that's what they're setting up
over there that it's that and it could
be alex jones trying to capitalize on
this where he has a camera in the room
for a documentary who knows um but here
is the law and crime but someone may
have someone may have been in put some
credits on the in this let's watch
mr jones
did you know that 12 days ago
12 days ago
your attorneys messed up and sent me an
entire digital copy of your entire cell
phone with every text message you've
sent for the past two years and when
informed
did not take any steps to identify it as
privileged or protected in any way and
as of two days ago it felt free and
clear into my possession and that is how
i know divide to me
[Music]
oh my god i can't it was it had to be
done i had to make it
i don't i don't know if this lawyer like
the the sandy hook lawyer if he
practiced that or what but i mean it was
just like
it was so perfect because look at the
this is the look on alex jones's face
he's not only but
also the angle they were on him and
they're like all right quick we want to
pan over
and sprite i get the reaction the law
and crime whoever is running that camera
they did a perfect job perfect job
amazing amazing even with the limited
amount of production that you had in the
room you did a fantastic job whoever's
running the camera wrong crime it was
unexpected delight
oh my god because
you know of course
that wasn't the end of this drama but
this but this attorney you saw him
sitting there yeah right
he was like oh just like finger in the
mouth tapping his lip he's like
right here's here's the uh here's here
he is um you know he's like
now i wonder
what do you think gabe because there's a
lot of theories out there right and i
and i know we've talked about a few of
them
in private and even on the show there's
a few theories that say that maybe this
guy
maybe this guy did this on purpose but
there could be a lot of different
reasons why he did it on purpose right i
i want to believe that there's not this
coin you know right well you would i
mean the thing so what happened was you
know there said oh we want all of the
text messages that have to that mention
sandy hook we want to see what he was
saying
during this time about i mean you mean
the sandy took hook attorneys were
working right he was like i want to see
the text message i want to see the
communications that were all mentioned
in sandy hook to to to show
that there was intent like you knew this
was a lie
and you continued to push it right
and you did it to millions of people and
these these victims these families had
to deal with even more stress and trauma
now
they asked for that and what ended up
happening was three years not even two
years three years of text messages and
communication had been sent over to the
plaintiff which was the attorney for the
sandy hook parents and he
gets this [ __ ] and he's like oh my god
this is a [ __ ] gold mine right which
by the way i'm sure he's already gone
through and searched for [ __ ] roger
stone and stuart rhodes and like trump
like all these things well so i was i
was on staring john's show with kelly
jones oh alex jones's ex-wife right
and
you know we were kind of talking about
this
and she actually said that that she
didn't know if
if alex
actually text a lot she thought it would
probably be dictation text so she
thought that it's going to be like alex
but can you imagine
can you imagine
alex jones like dictating his text like
he does his show and the demons
and the democrats the demons the cabal
the blood-sucking ball comfy i mean he's
sitting there dictating this into the
phone so
roger stone right come on
you know i don't know well come over
dinner come come [ __ ]
shot on my balls like there's something
it's good he's got his dad he's got
intimate messages so that's that's the
next uh thing that i want to show here
in this whole drama of
these text messages
is the fact that
because well we were on the show when
when that moment happened we were on the
show and we kind of pulled it up yeah
yeah and and i was like hey you know
that like at the time i was like two
years like 2022
2020
21 jan 6 is right in the middle there
like
is there any possibility that this guy
said something alex jones mentioned in
preparation
and uh during the day and after the day
with certain people that are of interest
to the january 6 committee i wouldn't be
surprised if they came for that and then
after the show had ended i think within
an hour so rolling stone had an article
that was saying uh the the jan six
committee was subpoenaing what was was
requesting a subpoena of those
of those text messages from the sandy
hook lawyer
but it enters in it enters in a new
chara well not a new character but a new
character to this trial right but one
we're familiar with in the jan six saga
with the oath keepers and the proud boys
which is roger stone and i'm trying to
find the clip of the moment
when
when the sandy hook lawyers describe
here it is here it is describe the the
messages
from alex jones to roger stone let's
listen and and things like like mr jones
and his intimate messages with roger
stone are not confidential they're not
traits
none of them so he says his intimate his
intimate conversations yeah it's real
you know i i would
think that private like you yeah yeah
yeah you would you well i'm i don't know
maybe he said private he was good to say
private or he was thinking privates you
know those are i don't know i don't know
it seems like this attorney
chose that word india very well i mean
look he's got a piece of paper in front
of he's got his whole like this is why
he's you know probably in preparation
knowing
that they're like oh [ __ ]
everyone is putting alex jones on blast
and mocking him on all of these
different channels and and news stations
because of that
we've had your text for 12 days now
and uh
nobody said that it was protected and
then alexander's like
oh [ __ ] right and he's like oh well
there's your perry mason but we like
tried to recover from it yeah and he
couldn't
because the damage was already done
right so of course it was
the uh the plaintiff the the uh
uh the the sandy hook lawyer came in
prepared he had the whole thing he's
like this is why
we will not allow these text messages to
be removed or struck and or struck from
the record
because and then he wrote down intimate
messages
with roger stone right he went through
he made sure to go through those things
because he's seen he's seen this well
he's either seen him or heard him
whatever these messages are solemn saw
the pictures
pictures that were sent back and forth
that they were sharing i don't know what
they were doing but yeah but but again
like we said on the show um before
he knew what he was doing
and he intentionally whether he took a
cue like
a page out of the jan six book
but he knew exactly what
what type of language would get the
clicks and would get people to follow up
and write stories about it right the
intimate word was important well and i
also think that actually invoking roger
stone's name is important because i
think what he's doing here is he's he's
calling
very specifically that hey
there might be some things the select
committee
wants to hear and wants to listen to and
see here um it's and the roger stone
stuff is juicy
it's juicy and which leads me to
uh on our bonehead of the weak
contestants the winner of the bone end
of the week
of course mr alex jones how could he not
be it was like it wouldn't even erase
right out of the gate man he was like
when
and it's mainly because of these text
messages yeah um obviously now we know
we know in the trial we have the first
verdict here now the 4.1 million on the
actual damages that is going to be
awarded to the sandy hook family in this
case
um it look they're gonna
be convening for the
punitive damages which
obviously this is uh and it seems to be
in favor of alex jones but like we've
discussed on the minus touch network we
did a little news clip for them where we
we we talked about that breaking news of
that verdict where
the the punitive damages only appears
that it can be twice as much in this
case as the actual damages which was
awarded the 4.1 so it seems like the
most that's going to come out of this is
possibly 12.3 million something like
that
plus i think there's attorney fees that
he has to pay or something and then
there's also the fines that right that's
right he owes because he's this isn't
the beginning of it this is just that
he's already guilty right this is them
deciding just the amount right it's
whatever million and a half or so and
finds that he's owed to
those families already because right
that he's been trying to pull right so
so in
in summation the 4.1 plus now the jury
may come back with punitive and they may
come up with some kind of pie in the sky
number like 100 or 150 or 200 whatever
that case
is and then
possibly
um
it could be the just double the amount
but the only amount no matter what they
come back with the maximum is double of
the 4.1 but also there's cases in
connecticut there's another cases in
texas so alex jones the bone end of the
week is not out of the woods here but i
want to play you i found this i think
ron yeah ron posted here
this is hilarious this is actually alex
jones
with his attorney in his studio trying
to explain the text messages
and you can tell why alex jones is
terrified that these text messages are
out in the open it has nothing to do
with these sandy hook cases not a
goddamn thing and i actually i end a
conversation with kelly jones ex-wife
that she's gonna try to get these text
messages too because she still has
ongoing lawsuits with him and he's not
he's not scared of that alex jones
projects exactly what he's scared of
exactly where the evidence is because he
has his attorney on his show to tell his
audience don't believe the stuff that
they're gonna say because it's the truth
don't believe it don't believe the thing
that they're just repeating verbatim of
what i sent right text right watch this
watch this um
weird piece of footage every major
platform is alex jones's phone has
fallen in
to the january 6 committee's hands
here's my lawyer or counselor or advisor
robert barnes give me a statement here's
my i don't know what this guy is here's
this dude i got off the street and i
sent it to my lawyer right this guy
who's one of the bench outside he's like
here's one of the guys that [ __ ] up
and gave all of the text messages to the
other side he's going to explain
what he why why he [ __ ] up yeah this
is so this is so dumb number one
he's lying here
where he's trying to tell his audience
that the january 6 committee already has
these which that's not the case yeah my
belief is here and we need to track this
down of exactly the timeline but i would
bet
that there were attorneys
from the january 6th select committee
that as soon as that moment happened
someone ran in a room like holy [ __ ] did
you just see what happened in austin
texas yeah like nope they pulled up the
video and immediately they they started
on the subpoena for those records now
because we do know we do know that the
select committee has subpoenaed those
records we do not know if the doj has
done it yet we don't know that but
here's the thing doj is gonna get those
records from the from the select
committee at some point because they
have come to an agreement on trading
information
just the timing
is a little lagged there but let's watch
how this attorney explains
to alex jones's audience how this is
this is all nonsense don't believe the
thing that anyone but alex tells you
absolutely i've been doing
constitutional law for a long time and
while i am not a representative of
infowars i am a representative that
cares about the constitution and in that
capacity the fourth the fifth and the
sixth amendment to the united states
constitution prohibit somebody from
illicitly obtaining your attorney-client
privilege protected information so here
we go so here we go here we go so this
this thing here where he's like he's
trying to explain amendments to alex
jones's audience because you know they
can't they can't make it past the first
or second amendment right right right
they know that they know the fifth one
now i mean like right oh
eric trump is that a 500
they know that fifth one really good but
they skipped they skipped three four and
when they
yeah figured out five now they're the
six so he's trying to explain to their
audience what amendments are and which
which numbers mean which thing let's
listen this goes all the way back to
andy griffith shows in the 1960s this is
how universally understood this
precepton principle is so what the
january 6 committee is doing why did why
did he say the annie griffith show what
the [ __ ] i don't know
he's like i don't know i don't know
did they do like a big survey to see
like they're like other shows alex jones
his demographic is watching nick at
night and they're watching the andy
griffith show
and they're like yep people will get
this reference people well here's the
thing probably because the people who
are buying those herbal supplements are
an older demographic and they're
probably the ones who are watching that
show probably well and that's what
they're like you got to give in you got
to give it a time a time period
reference because i know the exact one
i'm going to use andy griffith show
all right okay
which i'm i'm not dog in the andy
griffith show i love andy griffith yeah
i love it it's a very odd reference to
me right and you know what's funny about
the andy griffith show it's a bunch of
[ __ ] liberals in the real small rural
town in america which is kind of funny i
don't know i'm just saying let's listen
to robert barnes constitutional lawyer
who is standing outside info wars
headquarters
is violating the fourth amendment right
against unreasonable searches the fifth
amendment right to due process of law
and the sixth amendment right to council
by seizing and stealing attorney-client
privileged communications that cannot
constitutionally belong to them it is an
outrage that should concern every
american because in this case like so
many other cases alex jones is everybody
and everybody is alex jones uh no
they're not no no they're not no
a big [ __ ] you to robert barnes do not
nope don't do that don't do that let's
let's just make something clear nobody
stole these text messages nobody
illegally obtained these text messages
what what happened was that alex jones
attorney the person who may made the dm
this week the dishonorable mention and
dino reynald
willingly gave those things because they
were requested
and right do he didn't give just the
sandy hook references of text messages
he gave everything for three years and
then when he note when when the when the
sandy hook lawyer even said hey you send
us all these text messages they didn't
say [ __ ] they didn't they filed they
filed the actual paper that said hey you
you sent me everything this is not this
is more than what i wanted and then once
he went to that 12-day period which is
the rule in the court if there's no
response to that then there's no big
deal and really um alex jones tried to
uh get the judge to give a mistrial this
is like the 18 000th time right right to
try to do a mistrial but they were
trying to use this argument that it was
illegally and it was certain
yeah the lawyers came forward and was
like hey you know we want to say that
this was privileged information and the
other lawyer from the sandy hook side
was like no no no no
you guys have properly done this in the
past so you know what you're doing
you've been notified and you promptly
said oh you know what this should be
removed and and then and in those cases
where it was privileged they gave those
messages back and deleted their copy
so nobody nobody other than the lawyer
for alex jones and alex jones
had those copies of that information
that had been deemed between uh
privilege between client and attorney
right
and now it's another moment where
they're trying to do that and the judge
was like okay first off this is like
your 17th time trying to ask for a
mistrial i'm not going to seal this
information and hide it from people you
guys had time to respond and you didn't
and you have done so in the past so you
know how this works i'm not going to
give you guys a mulligan you guys [ __ ]
up that's on you here's the clip let's
watch it
what's interesting to me is this is not
the first time
that materials like this have been
inadvertently produced in this case as
you may remember from prior hearings mr
barnes inadvertently produced materials
now in that case some of that
information ended up coming up they
ended up letting you keep some of it
when we ended up talking about it but
there were a german community economic
community excuse me attorney-client
communications in there which you don't
know about which i do which they did
follow 193.3 and they did identify those
slides page numbers said here is the
privilege and when that happened i
promptly returned them and destroyed all
my copies
mr reynold is right now
using a fig leaf of this motion to say
eye violet
to put a fig over his own malpractice
over his own absolute breach of his
duties to his own car and he's
attempting to put that on me
and doing it in front of a televised
audience that's what he's trying to do
so there it is where he's making his
claim that not [ __ ] that is not
what happened i don't think so you're
not going to get away with that which is
which is uh it seems to be a reoccurring
thing with this alex jones child because
i do want to say i believe the reason
why some of this is happening to alex
jones number one because he has a big
[ __ ] mouth and he won't shut up he
won't shut his [ __ ] mouth and that's
and and kelly jones's wife said that
when when we were talking to her
yesterday and she was saying look this
is just narcissism he can't control
himself there's nothing he can do and
she's like i actually to some degree
feel sorry for alex because people think
that this is all put on she said some
degree this is probably a mental illness
like when this judge treats him like
he's six years old
she's like and people are kind of making
fun of it and stuff because it's kind of
funny when she talks down to him but
she's like i actually think the judge
and even i believe and know
that alex yeah he has this mental
illness that he's not capable of knowing
this stuff like he's very capable of
knowing some of this stuff because of
his narcissism his ego and i think that
go and it and it projects on to the
attorneys and they're just like we're
going to win this like they
you've already lost yeah you've already
lost what are you talking about now i do
i do want to say
that um alex jones is the bonehead of
the week
but this decision for the 4.1 million
dollars a lot of people are going to
knock it a lot of people are going to be
upset because they don't feel like this
is enough money um but this this is this
is what we see with justice this is how
this civil trial is playing out and
there's going to be more civil trials
and i bet gamer i bet they're gonna mic
and camera those other civil trials way
[ __ ] better way better they're gonna
be like all right we need mike's here in
the corner here in the car right below
like we need mike's everywhere
you'll be you'll be walking it'll be a
land like a land like a landmine field
of of just mics that's right right now
the the most interesting part about
when you watch the sen or not the
sentencing but the but the actual um the
damage is verdict right right the
verdict of what alex jones is gonna have
to pay the family
the thing that struck me the most and it
kind of pissed me off is he wasn't in
the room and i think it probably pissed
those families off too so
i don't know if those punitive damages
if you'll be and he doesn't have to be
in in the he doesn't have to be in the
courtroom either for the punitive
damages decision right which is just
it's just more it just shows you that
that they don't give a [ __ ] there's such
[ __ ] boxes
and and they think they're above the law
they're cowards right right that's right
they're scared will not they will not
face like the only time that he was in
there and had to face the parents were
when the parents were on the witness
stand and he had to look at them and
when they were saying
directly to him you knew what you were
doing was wrong you knew this was wrong
and he just shakes his head and it's it
is the exact behavior of a child who's
like no i didn't do it despite the fact
that there are
video records of him on a show blasting
these families and these victims
and then and
in court on the stand
lying to the judge and the rest of the
jurors to be like no i never said that i
didn't do that when he was doing those
things just that past week
he's such a piece of [ __ ] such a piece
of [ __ ] and such a coward for not being
able to show up to see the damages that
he would have to pay so that those
families
could watch as he was given the verdict
of his damages but let's give him his
verdict here from the vote that you guys
gave him for bone end of the week let's
give him his dude
[Applause]
[Music]
alex jones you are a [ __ ] bonehead
you our audience
has decided you are the bonehead of the
[ __ ] week yeah you are the bone end
of the week and i'm sure here's the
thing i'm sure he will come back up on
bonehead of the week for these other
following
the follow-up trials which he has
another one in texas he has one in
connecticut like he is not done here no
we have already established he owes well
he is in the millions
of of fines and charges against him more
to come and i hope they [ __ ] take him
for all he's worth just every year this
[ __ ] every last single vile
penny that he's made [ __ ] him
and i appreciate you guys uh doing bone
end of the week every single week voting
go to twitter where you can vote at tony
michael's pod you can also vote here on
youtube so don't forget to subscribe
while you're here if you haven't
subscribed already so you can vote every
single week for bone end of the week
where you decide
you vote we break it down on friday
yep every single friday in the second
hour where we broadcast every single day
game monday through friday monday
through friday
noon eastern 11 000 saturday
on saturday what do we do on saturday we
have a recap the best of boom go
download the recap and then on sunday
what happens uh uh oh for the people who
missed the friday show of bone out of
the week we got a recap again
boom so go download every single episode
seven days a week on apple spotify
google
get it there and
thank you for joining us for this
episode of bonehead of the week stick
around we have some announcements right
after the song
[Music]
[Applause]
whoa bonehead of the week
so fantastic so fast good that was a
zoom in
when you watch it you know when people
are watching this it's like
yeah you got to go watch it on youtube
to get that effect
what what a hell of a week it was like
it felt like 500 pounds of shits
packed into 10 pounds yeah really it was
it was a lot of nonstop [ __ ]
[ __ ] just packed acts and all this
other dumb [ __ ] people talking about
alex jones like it is non-stop and
here's the thing
it's always the [ __ ] republicans
they're the ones causing every [ __ ]
[ __ ] to hit the fan
democrats like hey listen we just wanted
to give these people health care or like
hey we want to give these people rights
or like we didn't want to take away
these rights from these women and then
you've got people like ron desantis
who's like ah you know what i'm gonna
[ __ ] suspend this guy who said yes
women should have their own rights and
no one should say different well and and
thank you everyone out there for
participating in your democracy and keep
doing it keep engaging in your democracy
is so important rather you come here and
listen to us two hours a day you go to
the other shows on the midas touch
network that's super important you talk
to your family your friends your
community members people you go to
church with people that go to
the parents of your of the your your
your children's friends
the people at the grocery store because
it makes a difference it really does we
saw that
in full display in the primaries
especially with that kansas vote gabe
i'm so excited about that kansas vote
because not just not just the fact that
kansas women in kansas and men who
support women in kansas told the kansas
government and the kansas republican
legislator [ __ ] you you are not taking
away their rights you're just not going
to do it we're not going to allow you to
do it
but i believe that that is the mood
everywhere and i think i think those
percentages can be counted on as long as
we engage is the most important thing
for you to do for your democracy today
so stay tuned here
at the tony michaels podcast subscribe
on youtube
and stay tuned every single weekday
monday through friday noon eastern 11
central nine pacific on youtube twitter
twitch don't forget to follow us on the
tweety tweets at tony michael's pod and
then as gabe said earlier you can
download an episode every single day of
the week
monday tuesday wednesday thursday friday
saturday and sunday you can download an
episode days a week
apple spotify google your favorite
directory leave us
leave us
a five star review or whatever kind of
review they do yeah yeah each directory
is a little different but leave us a
review there help us out and get us to
some good reviews
on those directories until have a great
weekend have a great have a great
weekend safe weekend enjoy yourselves
you've earned it you have you have and
we'll see on monday noon eastern 11
central nine pacific same time same
place
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking